another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do at the foundation he's no  longer allowed to challenge abel to  unwinnable games like tic-tac-toe it was  three weeks before abel conceded a draw  it probably shouldn't surprise you that  abel legendary swordsman and component  of  scp-076 both takes himself very  seriously and has a bit of a competitive  streak that's why dr bright enjoys  getting under his skin by challenging  him to pointless and unwinnable games  like tic-tac-toe just to watch him get  steamed the problem is when able gets  steamed there tends to be a large amount  of collateral damage that's why during  containment breaches dr bright is  advised to keep himself and his snakes  and ladders board well away from the  affected area